another golden rule of Christmas is
don't all the work yourself delegate at
home I'm raising my own little brigade
of sous chefs who always willing to help
with any recipe that involves chocolate
and the possibility of licking the
mixing spoon
another thing I always do the day before
Christmas is knock up a batch of mint
chocolate truffles there child's play to
make and have a wonderful fresh mint
flavor the perfect after-dinner
chocolates right Megan Jack I need some
help yeah
chocolates mint truffles first things
first you want me to do just get this
block of dark chocolate and just break
up into small pieces
okay my goes for you jack that's for you
mate where'd you get that time phone
time but they smart right mint chocolate
truffles secret here is getting that
mint and flavor into the chocolate so
low missing do get a little bunch of
mint just lightly bruise it you can
flavor the truffles with whatever takes
your fancy from fresh chilli which gives
it a surprisingly delicious kick to
orange zest to a splash of brandy by
double cream and single cream in
the cream makes the truffles wonderfully
soft luscious and rich next add a
generous pour of honey which helps to
sweeten the dark chocolate now bring out
to the boil now the secret is we pour
that on top of the chocolate okay so in
literally got two minutes to get this
done quick that's why I need some help
yes can you beat this shot with a
rolling pin that's a very good idea
or would it be too steep no it was a
very good idea because what we can't
afford to do is for the Queen to reduce
of the cream reduces then the
consistency of the truffle becomes too
hard that's a very good idea jack you
know now gently with that then what your
[ __ ] got more than one boyfriend Jack
what's her name
Emma walking ball Emma for Christmas
don't tell me yeah a table to daddy's
restaurant next at 130 grams of softened
butter and to give the troubles of
glorious richness and Sheen break up
into smaller bits
yeah nice good once the cream and milk
have come to the boil really smell the
mint strain over the broken chocolate
smells just push that mint flavor
through there so everybody just come out
yeah so we just come out see how the
chocolates dissolving and that honey has
given a really nice glazed sweetness as
well because it's bitter chocolate
that's right dark chocolate and then the
butter starts to give the chocolate a
really nice shine so then what would
actually happen it that look at that
peaceful right that well it the spoon
reach out then pour the chocolate into a
container and chill in the fridge for
about an hour to firm up